now seven go now unquestionably those
hardest things again so so you just
gotta just like a detective you got to
look at it like a detective you got you
got okay that building came down so we
the people want to know what happened at
Tower seven Ackerman looks like a demo
looks like exploded it looked it must be
exploded that's the conspiracy theory
what does the government say nothing
it's not in the 9/11 Commission report
they deny it there's no work there's
they don't say anything they don't
acknowledge it after public pressure of
wanting to know if that was a controlled
demo or not we want a real investigation
finally in 2008 they fund this finally
came out a government agency comes out
and he's and they ask them they go why
he gives a little presentation at Tower
7 which was brought down because it got
too hot and then he starts fielding
questions and they said why didn't you
guys test for explosives this is what
this is all about you know what he said
the answer was there were no witnesses
that said they heard explosions that was
his answer and there's anything in this
video absolutely I mean after video
after video after video firemen
policemen witness after witness after
witness there's all on video all's video
right when it happens and then the bombs
went off and then before that plane and
then bombs are just and then the whole
Lobby was just bummed and then we turned
around we were going down the elevator
in the elevator blew up and this
everyone's saying bombs the newscasters
are saying while there that was like
everyone saying bombs are going off
everyone they took all and buried it
they were saying there's all this they
said this it's on video they're saying
we didn't have anything you didn't check
for explosives they go no we didn't
check for explosives there was no
witnesses that said they heard
explosions now I'm not going to get into
you know the over to or close to 3,000
architects and engineers you know that
are calling for reinvestigation family
members and whatnot
I'm a family member trying to find out
the answers to the murder of three
thousand plus people
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this
some kind of consciousness-raising on my
part before I was willing to look at the
possibilities and really you need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
I have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence has been brought
forward has got to come away with the
feeling that something has to be done a
real investigation has to be put forward
but now the example that I want I want
to strike is if again one innocent life
is tragic enough that's just horrible
Islam condemns it it doesn't condone it
but now imagine like if that we've been
off of that how many people have died
because of that in another part of the
world right so that cycle that hate now
that violence terrorism cycle so now the
feelings that you feel never forget now
you're bombing drone in all these people
people they don't put themselves and
other people's shoes not justifying not
at all killing innocent memory but what
are these people feeling they're human
beings too how it's like these people
are just less human what do you have you
talked with people would you ask them
like are you a do you innocent life
their blood here same blood save I mean
I mean everyone claims that yeah all
blood is equal but they don't really
treat it the most is trending unless
it's trendy that that's the problem we
live in like a very trendy society news
is trendy the last one or two weeks and
then it doesn't matter how important it
was it's gone right and and just
people's information people
understanding of the world is extremely
restricted you know and they don't
really understand before when we're
about to invade Iraq people couldn't
identify where Iraq was on a map many
people probably still can't do that I
mean they don't really know much about
the world yet we're supposed to be these
very highly educated enlightened
intellectuals today who are supposed to
understand things the vast majority
people don't understand things they
think they understand I think there's a
lot of over concert
in people's people's our moral compass
there's a lot of overconfidence in
people's view of what they think they
know about the world and the way the
world functions supposedly in this
enlightened time that we're living in
right despite all these people being you
know living misery dying getting killed
you know just having the resources stole
all of these things that are happening
either people they don't know about it
and they're not going to take any effort
to go and investigate and it should be
presented to us but it's not right
because of propaganda and war machine
and all of that stuff or people know
about it but they're they're distracted
you know what it's really sad I just
heard that a million people got killed
in Iraq that's really really bad it
bothers me but you know what let me just
go buy a cup of coffee and let's go
watch a movie we just num-num ourselves
and just get rid of it there's nothing
wrong with watching a movie or buying a
cup of coffee but to just forget about
that and all of a sudden we're just
going to entertain ourselves and that's
big that's the problem with our culture
I think is that even when people do find
out most people when they find out they
want to just remove that because they
feel like they can't do anything about
it but you know what they can do
something the fact that they know about
it the fact that they speak about it in
their own small circle of influence
that's going to influence other people
and eventually public perception public
opinion plays a major role in whether or
not you're going to go in and invade a
country or kill a group of people or you
know incite hatred against a particular
religious group or religious minority
that makes it different so even if you
think like you as a small person you
know you only have like ten friends
twenty friends what am I going to do I
can't save like the entire world yeah
you can't save the world but your
contribution is important and if enough
people do that then you can make a big
difference and people like Joe they
don't just have a small circle of
influence they have a huge circle of
influence so when someone like that does
a small part in removing some of these
myths talking about you know you know we
shouldn't be killing these people and we
shouldn't be staring you know putting a
hatred against them it plays a major
role major role changer
yeah and again the experts that we coded
one I'd like to mention dr. Pape from
the University of Chicago again he
clearly states and they don't bring him
on mainstream media because then that
would garner the the support of more
people to be against you know this hate
war cycle but and he talks about it's
all about foreign occupation little to
nothing to do with Islam but you have
this this force now coming out you know
with all the negative propaganda you
know spewing this false information so
now oh these people do honor killings
all these people press women all these
people basically making them less human
so now people just don't care they think
okay they deserve to be bombed exactly
just bomb them a box litter is exact and
blame the Islam the Islam is the problem
right to divert people's attention from
the real problem over here exploiting
people's resources you know their land
and whatnot what's really cut what's the
root problem causing this right it's not
it's not right exactly yeah so hopefully
this is our humble genuine attempt to
reach people like Joe Rogan and get you
and others like yourself on his show
that would that would also show a good
attempt on his side to be genuine and
not to yeah you know we balance well
down absolutely I would love to and if
he wants to even meet just privately
first or something like that I'm more
than willing to you know talks about
your the Imam at a big community in one
part of California in Orange County in
Anaheim California Anaheim California
Joe we have our good friend here also
the Dean of Academic Affairs for the
College of Islamic California California
California University their Islamic
studies yes so we have a person who's
qualified who can help
fact-check a lot of these things
anything else we missed I think that's
we got a lot covered here we covered
quite a bit there and there's a lot more
hopefully in the future we can hopefully
get a good response and people can help
get this pushed us out there to mr. Joe
Rogan and if we get you on the show he
get we get him on the show he's ever in
Chicago
is open and if he gets you hopefully
this has produced much good and if not
hopefully the people that watch this
they have a better understanding and the
haters are we just going to hate it
doesn't matter people just look for a
reason to be angry something to you know
take and throw yeah they're not gonna go
there are people like that but you know
what we hope to reach out to the people
who seem to be more objective and are
willing to listen yeah that's that's our
job and that's what we want to do next
we're out of time I like to thank you
thank you for thank you very much once
again and thank you guys thank you Joe
if you listen and all the people his
viewers our viewers and tune in to the
Dean show every week that's what we're
here to sincerely try to deliver clear
up the misconceptions and deliver the
true message of Islam and we'll see you
next time until there subscribe if you
haven't already like share get this out
some more people can benefit see you
next time next week same time same
channel until then peace be with you
Salaam like - oh we accursed people to
come to us